well I'm honored to to get to talk to
you guys again it's always fun to talk
to this group and and to begin to build
these relationships between and deepen
the relationships between computer
science and economics I really
appreciate that the Simon's Institute is
a sorceress um what I want to talk about
today came out of consulting project the
title is adverse selection and auction
design for internet display advertising
and has a couple of co-authors Nick are
nasty who's I don't think he's here
today graduate student on the on the job
market this year and Marissa Beck who is
a graduate of the Stanford economics
program I actually began this with
Marissa and Nick made enormous
contributions afterwards and became a
co-author um and so I want to talk to
you about advertising and I and I want
to set some context on so you know
before the advertising than the internet
that was advertising before and the
advertising really dates back to the
19th century and one of the famous
advertising pioneers John Wanamaker has
a quote that's often mentioned in
business schools which is that half the
money I spend on advertising is wasted
the trouble is I don't know which half
now this was at the time if you could
imagine putting a newspaper
advertisement out about a sale or
putting a set of advertisements outdoor
more more recently television and
newspaper advertisements out you have no
idea if your sales go up to which ad
people are responding and which of your
advertising programs have been
successful and the the story we usually
tell about the internet is that that's
not no longer true because people click
on ads and the and you can tell if I put
a particular ad down how many you know I
have an ad campaign I show an
advertisement on the front page of yahoo
I see how many people are clicking on
that ad and I know something about how
the ads perform but that's actually a
simplification because the the internet
actually has both kinds of ads on it so
here's a actually I originally got
involved in this because
a client who's among whose customers
were newspapers that were advertising
and here's the Miami Herald this is an
example of an ad from last spring here's
south motor oil and wash 2495 there's
nothing to click on here it's a
traditional brand ad and just the same
old fashioned kind of brand dad that you
would have shown on newspapers of half a
century ago here's brickell heights this
is a tower that's that was getting ready
to open and they want people to be aware
of this so that they will rent
apartments in this newly to be built or
maybe at that time already built
structure and nothing to click on these
are just ordinary old fashion brand ads
just to set some context in the actual
consulting project the way that was
described to me as you know you have a
the newspaper has its sales people go
out to the local Ford dealer the local
Ford dealers can have a sale for the
weekend the newspaper is selling the
representative newspapers selling some
ads to this local Ford dealer and they
and after he's sold some ads for the
print edition this is five years ago or
so after he sold some ads for the print
edition that the salesman would say by
the way you really ought to buy some ads
in our online edition too we have you
know now a large fraction of our
customers who are reading our paper
online and he'd sell basically the same
ad online as he was selling in the in
the print edition now of course you all
know that there we also have these new
fangled or new fashion performance ads
these are you know here's an ad your
social network United learn more and you
click on it and off they off you go to
do something or this ad over here which
is a savings account offering the
amazing rate of 0.95 percent only in
modern times is that an amazing rate and
if you click on it you can sign up for a
savings account so these are the the new
fashion performance ads and these guys
have really pretty good information
about what are they place the RADS about
what the performance is okay so so I
want to
distinguished in this talk between these
two types of ads what I'll call brand
ads and what I'll call performance ads
branded by brand ads I mean ads where
the goal is awareness and image and
where the traditional advertising
objective is reached and repetition you
know Disney has a has a movie that's
going to open this weekend it wants
millions of people to become aware of it
it wants to reach some numbers of
millions of people and to have them see
for ads so that they you know they see
it repeatedly and become aware and stir
and start some buzz going and they get
real attendance over the weekend it's
targeted to a large group the large
numbers of impressions typically they're
guaranteed delivery which is that i have
a contract that says i'm going to get a
million impressions or five million
impressions whatever it is it could be
Ford's weekend auto sale or Disney's
movie opening or a shopping centers
location that advertise in that way as
opposed to the kinds of ads that you
guys more often think about where you
you're trying to get some measurable
action you want somebody to click on the
add to fill a form to buy something the
these ads are targeted to an individual
often based on cookies on the
individuals computer the the number of
impressions is often smaller I want you
know I want people who abandoned
shopping cart in at my store I want them
to come back and complete the purchase
it's a small number of high-value
impressions rather than millions of low
value impressions they tend to be
targeted in bought one by one these days
at auction so hurts for car rentals
Amazon retargeting people who have left
something in the store a quick and
mortgage maybe is maybe it's targeting
people who have recently searched about
mortgage refinance and read an article
about mortgage refinance or visited a
site about mortgage refinance they'll be
targeting very distinct relatively small
classes of individuals the so these are
caricatures I mean real ads are not all
squarely in one of these two categories
but this represents a real distinction
that's present on the
on the web okay so there's a danger of
adverse selection here that is the brand
advertisers are selecting impressions
often n mass they receive deferred and
aggregated data about a performance of a
whole ad campaign they you know the the
ford dealer doesn't really know which of
the ads is bringing the customers in and
you can too easily distinguish
low-performing ads and publishers
whereas these performance advertisers
are using private cookies they receive
immediate detailed data they can quickly
identify low-performing guy ads and
publishers and stop using them so if the
value of the ad impressions is
positively correlated for both types of
advertisers brand advertisers may suffer
adverse selection it could be that on
that on that website that you know the
I'm looking for desirable ads there are
people who visited my store but they're
also i'm also preferring to target
high-income people or people who I know
are responsive to advertising from
information I have about them and if I'm
picking off those ads and leaving for
you the low-income people and the people
who are not responsive to advertising
you're not too happy about that okay so
so this is what we in our group called
not quite optimal a market design the
we're interested in robustness you know
if you if you follow the literature and
optimal mechanism design or optimal
market design the the least within
economics it's mostly about writing down
an optimization problem with well
specified parameters and more in the
spirit of things that you guys often do
in computer science we're looking for
things that that perform well for a
market design that performs well over a
wide range of distributions and I'll
give you some ideas about that shortly
okay so here's the model we're going to
be looking at there are n plus 1
advertisers in this model so I'm imagine
that you're like in the example I gave
you the Miami Herald has some space on
to show on its page and n is greater
than or equal to 2 the value to
one of these guys is going to be a brand
advertiser that is if I show if I show a
brand ad it's going to be that brickell
towers add that I showed if I show
performance at it's going to depend on
who wants that impression and the value
of an impression to an advertiser is
going to be assumed to be this number X
I which is the product of two terms it's
C which is a random variable that we
will call the common value factor so if
you have somebody viewing the page who
has high income and is responsive to
advertising and generally that's a
generally high value person for
everybody and mi which is the match
value factor which is idiosyncratic it
has the I subscript it's it means that
for advertiser I the skies a
particularly good match or not depending
on whether mi is high or low the
assumptions are that advertisers 0 the
brand advertiser doesn't really observe
his value he just has a he can't tell he
knows the performance of the whole ad
campaign but he can't tell the value of
a particular impression the performance
advertisers do observe their values the
common value factor and here sooo so
these are these sort of caricature the
the example I showed you here's an
important assumption the common value
factor is statistically independent of
the vector M the vector of match value
factors okay so we're going to break
this up into on the one hand variation
due to common values and on the other
hand variation due to match values and
the problem that the that the brand
advertiser has is he's worried that the
performance advertisers are bidding high
and taking away impressions with high
values of C and leaving impressions with
low values of C so the market design
challenge we want to compare the
restricted worst case performance of
different mechanisms on efficiency
grounds and I'm going to consider the
following mechanisms to do the
comparison the first is going to be a
benchmark that's theoretically not
achievable it's what will call the
omniscient mechanism in which you
actually observe see and
you can eliminate adverse selection
because you know what C is and you can
assign the items efficiently the second
is what we'll call the optimal mechanism
which is going to be a bayesian optimal
mechanism in which what the the market
designer will do is try to maximize
efficiency subject to instead of
constraints that are familiar in this
group the third is the second price
auction which is a kind of option that
is commonly used for these things and
the fourth is our new modified second
bid auction which is what this talk is
really about in which the highest
performance bidder wins if the ratio of
the highest to the second highest
performance bid exceeds a threshold okay
otherwise the ad goes to the brand
advertiser so that will be the the new
mechanism I'll be talking about and so
let's quickly run through these these
mechanisms that mission benchmark will
call on in which the auctioneer observes
both the bids and this common value
factor C so the somehow or another the
auctioneer manages to observe that and
if the auctioneer could separately
gather perfect information about the
common value factor C and decide the
allocation accordingly ignoring any
incentive constraints than the value
that we would get from each impression
would be the maximum of either C times
the expected value of M naught that's
the value to the brand advertiser or X 1
or X n the values to each of the brand
advertisers the expected value of that
maximum is the value that we could get
if we could observe see okay the
performance of other mechanisms is are
going to be compared to this this will
be in the denominator when we talk about
performance of mechanisms okay
bayesian optimal mechanism which will
call opt we're going to have our
performance advertisers bid and we're
going to have let's suppose that we have
instead of constraints so that they're
going to report op they're going to
report truthfully so what we'll do is as
a function of the truthful reports that
the bidders make we're going to assign
the impression to bit awry with
probability Zi of X so X is the vector
of values which are reported truthfully
by the brand advertisers and this is the
probability that the item is given to X
P I exercise expected payment given X
the goal is to maximize the total
expected value which is the sum I equals
0 to n of X i zi of x and it's this is
we're going to maximize this subject to
incentive constraints and participation
constraints and we're going to let opt
be the mechanism that does that so the 0
be done does not know Lexi here so are
you running a notional the other guys
also I'm sorry this is the so I should
have an expected value of x 0 for 4
actually here x0 equals expectation of
it I'm sorry there's no that's 0 is here
this is what I'm trying to maximize I'm
sorry this is this is correct this is
what I'm trying I don't know x 0 and and
the Zi is actually going to be the
probability that X I wins given X and
I'm going to have dominant strategy
incentive constraints for the
performance bidders but this is the
value that bitter 0 gets when his value
it's so this is the right objective it's
just finding brand advertisers yes yes
sir only only the performance
advertisers bid okay we have a contract
with the brand advertisers says we're
going to deliver you know a million
impressions over some period of time
subject to some performance advertisers
observe X but they denote observe seal
and this has important to avenge our
seed we'll come back to that so for now
that for now yes assume that the
performance at
Kaiser's observe X but not see ok so
this decomposition is our decomposition
not necessarily their decomposition okay
so in an example here's an example to
show you how awkward this can all be so
suppose that the match values m 1
through m n are iid that C can be either
one or two will call this low or high
each with probability a half that the
match value can be 12 or for each with
probability a third and that the
expected value of M naught is between
three and four ok this is just an
example optimally a performance
advertiser and with em n equal four
would be assigned this impression and
the with otherwise the impression would
optima be assigned to the brand
advertiser in this example so this is
what the solution looks like it's a bit
ugly the expected efficiency maximizing
assignment with two bidders is that if
the if the highest what is the system is
the higher the lower value if x1 is
between one and two and i think this
forgotten what notation i'm using i
think this means the larger of the two
x's for the brand advertiser is either
one or two that means that m1 is less
than or equal to 2 and that's less than
or equal to that's less than the
expected value them not so we should if
the high bid is one or two we should
give it to the performance advertiser if
x1 is eight we can infer for sure that
the highest value match value is 4 and
that's bigger than the match value of
the brand advertiser so in that case it
oughta go the item ought to be assigned
to the performance advertiser if x1 is
for then it could be that m1 is for or
it could be that m1 is too we don't know
which so the assignment hinges on
whether the expected value
m1 given x1 x2 is greater or less than
the expected value of them not and so
the assignment ends up depending on the
second highest bid if the second highest
if X 1 is 4 and x 2 is 1 then we can
infer that m1 is 4 and we ought to
assign it to the performance advertiser
if X 1 is 4 and X 2 is to then you can
calculate the expected match value is 3
which is less than that of the brand
advertiser so it ought to go to the
brand advertiser and if x 2 is for it
ought to go to the brand advertiser it's
all just algebra but the point is that
there's a statistical inference problem
that goes on here that you observe x1
and x2 and you're trying to separate and
somehow figure out what is the match
value and what's the performance value
when you assign the item accordingly ok
and the algebra just does that the main
thing the main takeaway is that this is
a statistical inference problem and and
so that highlights to be concerns first
opt is sensitive to detailed
distributional assumptions if we change
the distribution we're going to change
the way we do the statistical inference
we're going to get different looking
mechanism false name bidding if if we
have performance advertiser rent has X n
equal to 4 if he could submit an
additional bid with X and had equal to 1
and we then did an optimal statistical
inference we would and and assumed that
these were actually independent bidders
we'd be saying gee if somebody has a
value of 4 and somebody has a value of
one that means the highest match value
is 4 and this guy out a win um so the so
putting in an extra low bid could cause
a bitter that was otherwise losing to
become a winner adverse selection the
brand advertiser in this case wins four
nights of the high-value impressions of
the high-value impressions but
seven-ninths of the low value ones
forget that high that's low and that's
most problematic if the brand advertiser
feels uninformed about the impressions
and who else may be bidding brand
advertiser doesn't really know we just
want some assurance
is getting a fair set of impressions
okay so that's what opt looks like
here's a modified second bid auction and
I'm going to begin by characterizing it
by its properties so where did we come
up with this idea of taking the ratio of
the highest to the second highest bid so
this is going to be an axiomatic
characterization and then we'll do
something new miracle so a mechanism is
said anonymous among performance
advertisers if I'm going to omit the
details of the definition these things
are all obvious enough and I'll say them
in words it's anonymous if it's
independent of permutations that is the
you switch the order of the performance
advertisers the highest performance
advertiser wins for example the it
doesn't matter what the labels are in
the performance advertisers its strategy
proof if its dominant strategy for
everybody to report their value
truthfully this is these are familiar
idea it's fully strategy proof if in
addition to being strategy proof it's
both bitter false name proof which means
a bitter can't benefit by submitting
additional bids and publisher false name
proof if the seller can't benefit by
submitting low bids that's what we're
going to call fully strategy proof and
its adverse selection free if for every
joint distribution on the common value
factor and the match value factors for
which these things are statistically
independent Z naught of X the
probability that the item gets assigned
to the brand advertiser is statistically
independent of C okay so that's a
adverse selection free and a modified
second bid auction a direct mechanism is
a modified second bid auction if for
some alpha greater than or equal to 1 if
the ratio of the highest to the second
highest bid is strictly greater than
alpha then the highest performance
advertiser wins and pays alpha times x2
and otherwise the brand advertiser wins
and pays its contract price that's what
we mean by a modified second bid auction
and then the fair
is deterministic mechanism is anonymous
fully strategy proof in adverse
selection free if and only if it's a
modified second bid auction okay that's
the the characterization theorem and
actually I should make it let me let me
make this intuitive for you let's go
back to the conditions okay it's
anonymous among performance advertisers
that means it's got to be symmetric in
the bids of the performance advertisers
free of permutations modified second bid
auction clearly has that property
strategy proof so it has to be a
dominant strategy to report truthfully
and I think many of you know certainly
The Economist's know and I think
probably it's familiar to most of you as
well that the only time a mechanism in
this assignment on assignment context is
strategy proof is if for each bidder
there is a threshold that depends on
other bidders bids such that it wins if
its bid exceeds that threshold and in
that case it pays the threshold price
these are called threshold auctions or
threshold mechanisms modified second bid
auction is a threshold mechanism the
highest bidder wins if and only if his
bid exceeds alpha times the second
highest bid there's going to be just one
winner alpha times the second highest
bid is a threshold if he bids higher
than that he wins if he bids less than
that he loses it's in his interest to
report truthfully because if his actual
value was higher than the threshold he
wants to win he wants to at the
threshold price of his actual value is
less than the threshold he wants to lose
and so its dominant strategy to bid
truthfully and all of that can be
written down in symbols and made formal
but it's it's actually all very familiar
threshold auction stuff fully strategy
proof well now if you if you start
sticking in some low bid if you're the
winning bidder you're going to have to
pay alpha times x2 if you put it in a
higher bid you know if you put in a
little bit it doesn't affect anything if
you put in a bid that's higher than the
second highest bid all you can do is
make yourself loser pay a higher price
so it can't be in the interest of of a
bitter in general the
in order to be fully strategy proof this
what this ends up implying in the in the
formal proof of the theory is that the
the outcome can only depend on the two
highest bids if the outcome depended on
any bit other than the two highest
either the publisher or the bidder would
have some interest to put in that third
bid and manipulate the price up or down
so so this really just this this extra
condition really just means that the the
auction outcome depends only in the two
highest bids and adverse selection free
now here the idea is that if you take a
look again at the condition x 1 is C
times M 1 and X 2 a.c times m2 so if you
take a look at this ratio the sea
cancels in the numerator and denominator
and you just have em 1 over m 2 so the
event that the performance advertiser
wins is statistically independent of see
that makes it adverse selection free and
you can show generally that well I won't
even go into what you can show generally
this is the you can see that's a pretty
special condition you can if you have
something that depends only on the first
two bids this is the only mechanism
that's going to give you adverse
selection free the only anonymous
mechanism that will get you every search
free so and all that the proofs are
written down in the paper okay so that's
the axiomatic characterization that
motivates the why we did this I should
say that you know we had some
discussions with our client about what
they thought were reasonable models of
of adverse selection you know adverse
selection and auctions this
multiplicative model there's nobody's
going to have there's not never going to
be unanimity about what's a reasonable
model of how common value and match
value factors affect things but this
multiplicative model had great appeal to
the people I i was talking to so we that
was we settled on this model of it does
seem that there's some impressions that
are just pretty valuable because people
are responsive and they have high
incomes and the match value does seem to
be a separate kind of
but I don't want to defend that model to
vociferously it's just a model what I do
want to do is compare the modified
second bid auction with parameter alpha
the second price auction with reserve
are and and the omniscient mechanism so
that we see what these things look like
and for the comparison we're going to do
we're going to evaluate both mechanisms
in a worst case over a limited family of
environment so we're going to assume
that M 1 through m NR iid from some
distribution that C is drawn from some
distribution fc's drawn from some
distribution g there's at least two
bidders and the other than that and is
arbitrary and IAM not is some
non-negative number that's arbitrary and
so here's the theorem about the
comparison this compares second price
with reserved and modified second bid to
aam in the worst case with these very
weak distribution very weak these
independence type distributional
assumptions assuming Nash equilibrium
bidding by the brand advertiser both
modified second bid and second price
have similar worst-case performance if
you take a look at the value of the
modified seconded auction / the value of
M for the best for a parameter that's
optimized for the environment but then
you take the infimum over environments
the infimum over distributions after
distributions g numbers of bitters n and
means of the performance advertisers you
get a half and the same thing gives you
a hat the second price with reserve does
the same ok but if you further restrict
if you imagine that advertising that
match values are drawn from fat tail
distributions you imagine that the
what's really going on in brand
advertising is that there's a small
number of impressions that lead to most
of the value so now i'm talking about
power law distributions so if you
restrict F and G to be drawn from power
law distributions and actually for this
you only need to restrict f I probably
should have left out the mg here if you
restrict F to be drawn from power law
distribute
shins then the no I think if I'm going
to do both of these I need f ing sorry
so f ing to be drawn from power law
distributions then for the second price
auction this thing remains a half but
for the modified second bit options this
goes up 2.95 ID so what's going on here
let me try to give you some intuition
about what's going on here so how can
this thing jump up 2.95 this is the
surprise right this is the one thing
that most needs explanation and so
what's going on here is that in the
modified second bid auction what we're
looking at is the ratio of the highest
to the second highest bid and when we
get a really good match every once in a
while the ratio of the highest to the
second highest bid is going to be really
big these match values are statistically
independent and most of the value comes
from extreme values of the distribution
what I'll show you formally in fact is
that the ratio is so let me remind you
of some math a the power law
distribution random variables have a
power law distribution if and only if
their logarithms have exponential
distributions ok and so exponential
distributions i know very familiar to
people so so what that means is if you
take the maximum of a bunch of
exponentially distributed random
variables and you take and and the
second maximum the difference between
the max and the second max is also
exponentially distributed with the same
distribution right that's familiar from
waiting times and queueing theory and so
on right that the the last after after
you've received if you got one just one
person left who's waiting to be served
the remaining waiting time is still
conditional on the the second longest is
still exponentially distributed with the
same distribution so similarly for
ratios and power laws if you take the
ratio of the highest to the second
highest value that has a power law
distribution with the same same
parameter and so the so the ratio of the
highest to the second highest bid almost
all of the value
there lies in the lies and the very high
values of that parameter so so when this
guy wins you're you're picking up most
of the most of the value picking up most
of the high-value cases the guy with the
highest value to the guy with the second
highest value that ratio will be high
almost exactly in almost exactly the
same cases where there's a very good
match and where there's a where the
reason that the bids are high is that
there's a high common value where the
reason that the bids are high is that
the is that there it's a really good
person to advertise to then all of the
values will be high and if the if the
ratio is roughly one that means well
it's a good it's a good item to give to
the match value to the brand advertiser
and not an especially good item to give
to the brand advertiser and I've got
here was the F&G thing the for the for
this imp the shown in red that what I
need is that the match value
distributions have a power law the
intuition i just gave you involved match
value distributions being a power law
the G could be anything whereas for this
one I I could have left this out I've
added the restriction that the G is also
a power law distribution that if
anything should make this higher but
I've said even restricting G to be in
power law distribution this is still
just a half you get most of your web
server from just performance guys know
so this is the so this depends on so
it's not that's not the case in fact it
could be that the expected value of M
naught is 0 for example and all of the
welfare comes from the oh I'm sorry
quickly that the expected value of M
naught is an infinite it could be 0 it
could be infinite this is any expected
value of M naught
it could be infinite are you expect one
of the Barlow's of the four was so if
the expected value of M naught is low
than almost all of the value comes from
the brand advertisers if this is high
then almost all of the value sorry i
fell backwards if this is low almost
dollar value comes for performance
advertisers if this is high it comes
almost entirely from brand advertisers
wherever you are and no matter what
power law you have and no matter how
many bidders you have the worst case is
point 95 well intuitively is it true
that alpha will be increasing and
expected M not because that's how you're
going to get the value of yeah yeah so
what will happen is that you so you if
you have ads some class of ads that you
think is particularly valued of brand
advertisers you want the brand
advertisers to to win a lot of those ads
you set alpha high and so this this
involves the the newspaper in the
example I gave you adjusting alpha to
the mix that it thinks at wants of
performance and brand ads in order to
get the optimizer is that maybe that was
the answer to the question so thank you
for that Steve okay revenue performance
if you fix a number of bidders n and
assume that the publisher shares the
rents from the brand advertiser in any
fixed proportion so you imagine we have
this brand advertiser that we're writing
a contract with and and we're sharing
the value so that some fraction goes to
the performance advertiser and some
fresh to the brand advertiser and F's
from a power-law distribution then
there's some alpha so that the the
modified second bid auction also
achieves actually 94.8 percent of the
expected revenue from the corresponding
revenue maximizing strategy which will
call rev max so that you you it does
very well on revenues as well and that
i'm told that i was at the end so
I have a few minutes for questions it
seems odd shape of the functions that
you symphony valuations might really be
driving the result you've said that X is
C times am multiplicative relationship
but then and also in the power law
distribution you again at this very
special multiplicative relationship and
you end up finding that something based
on what issues works really well yeah I
imagined you know in your actual
newspaper example you don't know that
precisely this this forum evaluation
relationship holds do you have some
intuition about why you expect this to
degrade nicely in situations that aren't
exactly like this so so what we actually
so we're actually started this before
Nick got involved by the way where we
actually started was the question of is
it even possible to have an option where
the participants bid that's adverse
selection free and the so I think of
this thing as having been built in two
parts there was the part where we said
well gee if we had this multiplicative
relationship if this is the way you guys
conceive the value that there's high
value impressions and and good matches
and that the it's the product of those
two then it is possible to achieve
adverse selection freeness by taking a
new actually characterize the whole
class of functions that do that and then
if you add false name proof in this
there's only one function left it's this
ratio of the highest to the second
highest bid and and we sort of had
stopped there and then it was so that's
one piece it's a separate piece then the
power-law distributions we had examples
that we've done with power law
distribution that performed remarkably
well and so we sort of are in our
intuition for why it might perform well
is exactly what I've described and I you
know you've asked about the functional
forms the function power law is a way
that we formalize the idea that most of
the value comes from a few good matches
that was our what we were trying to do
how could this degrade badly so we have
we know some case
degrades badly so suppose that you have
power law type distributions we have fat
tails so most of the value comes from
good matches but let's say we have two
jewelry stores and what and you happen
to be a really high value customer for
jewelry stores so we get to high bids
from jewelers then the ratio is not
going to capture the fact that this is a
this guy's an especially good match for
jewelry stores so we know something
about when it degrades and it does come
from intuitive analyses of what the
mathematics is trying to capture namely
a lot of value comes from the from very
good matches and those matches tend to
be unique that seems to be what it takes
for this to perform really well two
serums are they the same outfit role so
the alphas are also two theorems with
outfits in them let's go back to the
heroes to the
okay uh where's the theorem okay really
revenue and oh you're asking about the
revenue and and the and the efficiency
and the answer is essentially yes the
essentially it's it's the what what
happens is that the I'm giving the so is
it the same out no I'm sorry the answer
is essentially no let me switch that let
me switch that answer it says there's a
sense in which it's essential
essentially yes that is what we do is
once you fix the fraction of value that
is going to the that's being captured by
the advertiser he just ignores the rest
of it and is objective and then the
problem looks just the same as the other
problem but with a lower value of um not
right he's he's he's saying that matches
and so valuable to me it's because the
brand advertiser is getting most of the
values so I'm going to resolve the
problem with a lower value of the AVM
not and then I'll get a lower value of
alpha does that answer your question
possibly but I don't understand the same
question yeah but what I understood that
answer to say is the Rev alpha is just
the same as the other alpha except solve
different problems lower em that's right
yes which could have a massive impact on
the on the efficacy we don't know yeah
so that is so all that depends on Delta
if I'm not very good at bargaining with
the brand advertiser so I get very
little revenue from the brand advertiser
then I'm going to bias the end and I'm
and if I'm trying to maximize revenue
i'm going to bias the auction in favor
of the performance advertisers if other
why if I'm very good at bargaining with
the brand advertiser I'll put in the app
I'll put in the opposite sort of bias if
I'm if it's sort of neutral that I get
the same fraction from both the brand
advertisers in the performance
advertisers then I'm interested in
maximizing efficiency so to the extent
that my ability to extract revenue from
the brain
advertisers is different than my ability
to extract revenue from the performance
advertisers I will be biased away from
efficiency in the corresponding
direction so it would be really nice if
there was a corollary that said if Delta
is point nine four days yet the revenue
that you get at least that in in the
revenue that is you that is you capture
94.8 percent of the icing so we could
have a theorem to that got the
efficiency and revenue align that's what
you yep got it yeah that would be
interesting i'll take a look at that
offline so i think coming back to the
comment about jewelry stores i said
independence i think is really important
right yes I've 'if and i both have our
farming video game that we're trying to
sell and basically the same game we're
always bidding about the same amount so
the brand advertiser is going to get all
of those yes that's right richard has
this more unique puzzle game and a few
insults and it's really not
representative anymore what's that brand
advertisers right so there's a lot of
things that could make this not
representative empirically i mean some
of the stuff is is empirical whether
this is whether these are good
assumptions or not there are other
things that are going on in this
industry you know that have become
increasingly important since we began
this research you know you have these
demand-side platforms that are not
putting in all the bids they're you know
they're just putting in a bid for one of
their clients and withholding bids for
other clients they're all sorts of
things going on that could make this not
match the current reality um so i think
what's important is exactly what we're
talking about to identify what the
characteristics are that caused it to
perform well or badly tick so that we
understand it well and then to do things
empirically and see how it works on the
data
useful to look at where the big gap is
so what connects to a single thing if
the top to our appetizers are very high
then you would give it to the brand
appetizer but what if there are key very
high ones and then there's a very low
one yeah so the reason so so it turns
out in our model if you didn't impose
false name bidding um then it would be
optimal to if you didn't if you didn't
require that the thing be fully strategy
proof that there be no no incentive for
false name bidding then the optimal
mechanism would depend on the ratio of
the highest to the lowest instead of the
ratio of the highest to the second
highest you can demonstrate that with
power law distribution so it's a
sufficient statistics result yeah so so
you know it would it would solve some of
that problem if there was correlation
but it would also expose the auction to
false name bidding which we think is a
serious problem and you know in an
anonymous mercury and what if you had
some sort of similarity score between
bidders right so you would say that I
veith and I are so similar that you
would make alpha really small in that
case so yeah so I mean you can imagine
variations like that again I've imagined
an anonymous market you're now dropping
anonymity and saying well we know if we
know something about the bidders maybe
we can undo the problem in that way and
then maybe so let's take further
questions upside this again